[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí a américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias e historias de nuestro
continente esto es lo que veremos hoy
desde hace semanas el control por el
multimillonario mercado legal de la hoja
de coca en bolivia enfrenta a los
cultivadores vamos a la paz para
explicarles el conflicto y los jóvenes
venezolanos vuelven a las clases en
medio de la controversia entre los
profesores que denuncian que no están
protegidos al no haber recibido la pauta
completa de vacunación contra el cob y
19 y los padres que ansían la
presencialidad ya que creen que la
educación a distancia no funcionó
hablamos con ellos en caracas y la
violencia de las pandillas está
descontrolada en haití 17 misioneros
norteamericanos 16 estadounidenses y uno
canadiense fueron secuestrados por un
grupo que exigía una suma imposible por
liberarlos les contamos cuánto en
minutos
vamos de inmediato a bolivia para
nuestra historia principal a pesar de
que la mayoría de los cultivos de la
hoja de coca en el país andino van al
narco la venta legal genera millones de
dólares anuales según la onu la planta
es muy importante para la cultura
boliviana pues se mastica y es un factor
de socialización desde hace semanas los
cultivadores de coca batallan por el
control del mercado legal de la hoja
nuestra corresponsal en la paz mery vaca
habló con los cocaleros y nos preparó el
siguiente reportaje
los cocaleros afines al gobierno
celebran la fundación de un tercer
mercado de la coca en bolivia que
estaría al margen de la ley han dado ese
paso tras su pugna con los cocaleros
contrarios al oficialismo por el control
del comercio de la coca estamos creando
el nuevo mercado de coca para los yungas
y para el pueblo boliviano hermanos a
quien no vamos a tener diferencias
políticas sin embargo el nuevo mercado
ha agravado el conflicto porque
profundiza la división entre los
cocaleros
[Aplausos]
a
la venta legal de hoja de coca es muy
importante en bolivia en el país la
planta se mastica se usa como un
estimulante y un factor de socialización
el analista crítico gregorio lanza
estudioso y también consumidor de la
hoja de coca explica su visión de la
pugna actual por la última raíz del
último comunista es que evo morales
quiere controlar también los yungas de
la paz ya la dirigencia de lyon desde la
plaza para de esa manera tener el
monopolio entre comillas de todos los
productores de bolivia según la onu la
coca legal en bolivia tuvo en 2020 un
valor de hasta 400 49 millones de
dólares un negocio importante que ha
sido afectado por las peleas entre
cocaleros muchos comerciantes sólo
quieren vender al margen de las disputas
ahora mira como en la calle vendemos
nueva buena comunidad para atender a que
la ley sólo reconoce dos mercados
legales para la coca en bolivia 1 en la
paz y otro en cochabamba de consolidarse
un tercer mercado con el aval del
oficialismo la coca que antes unía a los
cocaleros de los yungas serán la causa
de mayor discordia
vamos a chile para revisar la imagen de
la semana los ciudadanos salieron
nuevamente a las calles porque se
cumplieron dos años del estallido social
el 18 de octubre de 2019 los chilenos
protestaron por primera vez en rechazo
al aumento del pasaje del transporte
público pero esa fue sólo la gota que
derramó la copa a partir de ese día los
ciudadanos siguieron manifestándose
contra la desigualdad social un reclamo
que derivó tras varios meses en la
convocatoria a la asamblea constituyente
que precisamente tuvo su primera sesión
esta semana para empezar a reescribir la
constitución que reemplazará a la
vigente que chile heredó de la dictadura
de augusto pinochet
el regreso a clases en venezuela el 25
de octubre genera posiciones encontradas
entre profesores que denuncian que no
están protegidos contra el cob y 19 y
que las instituciones no tienen la
infraestructura para garantizar la
bioseguridad y los padres desesperados
porque sus hijos retornen a la
presencialidad al alegar que la
educación a distancia no funcionó veamos
el informe de nuestra corresponsal en
caracas ni con el colesterol
katiuskas profesora de la única escuela
pública secundaria del chiquito un
pueblo retirado en las montañas de
caracas esta escuela abrirá sus puertas
luego de años y ocho meses cerradas por
la pandemia es una infraestructura
contada de manera generalizada en mal
estado no hay por ejemplo agua corriente
en los baños ni electricidad en los
salones hay que detenerse hay que
realmente crear las condiciones y luego
entonces hablarse de presencialidad no
es una situación aislada más del 80% de
las escuelas en venezuela son públicas y
casi su totalidad presenta fallas de
infraestructuras y servicios básicos
según el gremio de educadores
pese a ello los padres siguen adelante
con la inscripción de sus hijos y
yamilet no le importan las condiciones
quiere que su hijo vuelva ya a las aulas
su educación dice quedó a la deriva con
un sistema a distancia que no funcionó
le mandan su transforma sabes que no
entiende no encuentro un profesor que le
explique por qué no que por la pandemia
que por el contagio que por aquello que
por esto en dos imágenes el niño me
queda ves en el ano katiuska la entiende
académicamente debemos volver pero está
por otro lado la seguridad y la vida
fanny también es profesora tiene tres
títulos universitarios dos posgrados 23
años del servicio tan solo cinco dólares
al mes coincide en que no hay
condiciones para el regreso a clases
presenciales pero no se opone tiene
otros miedos de 25 estudiantes que
puedan haber en un salón habían logrado
las competencias dos o tres niños
es terrible estés demasiado grave pero
que pero encuentro tenías que
promoverlos a todos el que sabía y el
que no sabía porque como le podías ir
que ha reprobado si nunca te sentaste
con él a darle clase el gobierno comenzó
a vacunar a los educadores en marzo y
según ha dicho el 80% de estos está
cabalmente inmunizados sin embargo la
cifra es cuestionada por el gremio de
educación y la oposición en caracas a
nicole kolster france24 y en haití
revisamos la cifra de la semana 17
millones de dólares
ese es el rescate que pidió la pandilla
que secuestró a un grupo de misioneros
norteamericanos un millón por cada uno
para liberarlos haití sumergido en una
profunda crisis ostenta la tasa de
secuestro per cápita más alta de la
tierra los residentes de la capital
puerto príncipe iniciaron una huelga en
rechazo a la violencia de las pandillas
y los secuestros
libertad es el reclamo en las calles de
haití con el secuestro de 17 misioneros
norteamericanos como antesala piden que
termine este tipo de violencia en el
país
[Música]
y hacen mucho por nosotros los
misioneros construyeron nuestras
escuelas pagan nuestras cuentas nos
ayudan con todo así que no podemos
guardar silencio
los misioneros fueron raptados tras
visitar un orfanato en las afueras de
puerto príncipe lo llevó a cabo la banda
400 magos o una de las más peligrosas de
haití operan principalmente en el
distrito 4 bouquet en las afueras de la
capital una ciudadana estadounidense
hija de uno de los secuestrados habló
bajo condición de anonimato
pensando en la inseguridad mentí es un
flagelo que existe desde hace varios
años pero ahora ha alcanzado
proporciones insoportables al verbo by
disqus explica el fbi que sin una acción
concreta no se detendrá veremos un
aumento en los casos de secuestro
en lo corrido de 2020 se han registrado
más de 600 secuestros en haití en los
primeros 15 días ocurrieron 119 de ellos
asesinatos robos violaciones y guerra de
pandillas han intensificado el caos en
un país que ya se enfrenta a la pobreza
extrema la inestabilidad política la
polis estás la policía la élite política
y económica ninguno de ellos está
preocupado por las pandillas porque
todos son parte de la economía criminal
la inseguridad en haití es un mercado
enorme y todas estas personas están
involucradas algunos grupos aprovechan
esto para obtener beneficios políticos
mientras las pandillas operan sin
control las fuerzas de seguridad no
pueden mantener el ritmo
haití tiene 16 mil policías pero muchos
de ellos trabajan para particulares
mientras que otros han optado por huir
del país
vamos a eeuu que este mes está viviendo
una ola sin precedentes de acciones
sindicales tan grande que ha llevado a
que se acuñó el término strike cover es
decir strike de huelga y october de
octubre en inglés más de 50.000
empleados están en huelga o amenazan con
irse a paro si no se mejoran los
salarios y las condiciones en un mercado
laboral apretado es decir con abundantes
ofertas y pocos dispuestos a tomarlas
debido a que la pandemia llevó a las
personas a reevaluar sus prioridades
veamos más en el siguiente informe
el sonido de bocinas una muestra de
apoyo para la huelga 10.000 empleados de
14 plantas diferentes de jong y
abandonaron su trabajo la semana pasada
es la primera gran huelga para el
fabricante de equipos agrícolas en 35
años los trabajadores dicen que luchan
por ganarse la vida dignamente
no tengo idea cuánto tiempo vamos a
estar en esta huelga pero estoy
dispuesto a hacerlo todo el tiempo que
sea necesario solo para que nuestro
punto se entienda escenas similares se
repiten en todo el país en plena
pandemia los trabajadores hartos de los
sacrificios que han hecho exigen mejores
condiciones los empleados de las plantas
de cereales de que lux rechazan el trato
de la dirección wheeler hay personas que
no tienen días libres programados desde
hace meses y meses todos hacemos
sacrificios enormes para trabajar en
esta planta y queremos ser reconocidos
como un solo sindicato con niños unos 31
mil trabajadores de la salud en
california y oregón también apoyaron la
huelga toda esta acción industrial se ha
materializado en el término estricto ver
una alusión a strike huelga y octubre el
mes y termino ha sido adoptada en las
redes sociales incluso por algunos
demócratas progresistas
hashtag extracto ver viene con mucha
fuerza después de años de hacer
desatendidos y subestimado y sobre todo
durante la pandemia los trabajadores se
están comenzando a convocar huelgas en
todo el país desde trabajadores de
producción hasta trabajadores de jong y
ver y kellogg's y muchos más después de
décadas de declive las tasas de
afiliación sindical aumentaron por
primera vez en 2020 en estados unidos y
los activistas laborales ven a un amigo
en la casa blanca después de que yo
vaivén prometiera a ser el presidente
más pro sindical jamás visto
y seguimos en eeuu para el cierre del
mes de la hispanidad por primera vez el
musical chicago hizo una presentación
especial para la comunidad hispana
[Aplausos]
[Música]
este año el musical ganador del premio
tony celebró la noche viva broadway como
tributo a los talentos latinos y a las
audiencias latinas la presentación del
18 de octubre incluyó algunos segmentos
en español de la mano de las tres
estrellas latinas que hay actualmente en
el elenco and a villafañe bianca
marroquín y paulo szot el musical
chicago está cumpliendo 25 años en
broadway y es considerado el musical
estadounidense de mayor duración en la
historia de la industria estamos
celebrando que son los tres latinos
representando estelarizando la obra el
hecho ahora de tener nuestra noche para
los latinos y que nos han permitido dar
pedacitos aquí y allá en español pues es
mucho orgullo hablar mi lenguaje mi
idioma en broadway y me despido con
música porque 20 años después del
lanzamiento de su álbum en español
christina aguilera vuelve a cantar en
nuestro idioma para mis muchachas es la
nueva canción de la cantante
estadounidense con las argentinas
nativas y nicole y la de ascendencia
mexicana
vekic y la canción cuenta con un marcado
carácter latino y es que el padre de
aguilera es de origen ecuatoriano está
por verse si cristina lanzará un nuevo
disco completo en español gracias por
acompañarme en esta emisión de aquí
américa soy natalia cabrera pueden
seguirme en redes sociales en la
dirección que viene en sus pantallas en
la producción estuvo joan y agudelo
sigan con más en france 24
la canción me cae como anillo al dedo
demostrar
[Música]
y muchas
si estoy flotando con curvas como sea
que aún no está de acuerdo con esto
[Música]